- Hi, my name is Jacob
Scott Thomas Bertrand,
and I play Hawk.
- Hi, I am Mary Mouser, and
I play Samantha LaRusso.
- Hey, I'm Peyton List, and I play Tory.
- Hi, I'm Xolo Maridueña,
and I play Miguel Diaz from Cobra Kai.
Today we are with Buzzfeed to take a quiz
to find out if we're more
Cobra Kai or Miyagi-Do.
(cool mid tempo music)
First, choose the word
that best describes you.
Our options are: loyal,
kind,
supportive,
brave, ambitious,
and reliable.
I think, right off the bat,
I'm gonna have to go
with ambitious, I think.
I wouldn't consider myself brave.
I can cross that one
right off off the bat.
What about you guys? What
are you guys thinking?
- I think supportive.
I mean, I wanna say loyal.
Definitely not reliable.
I'm late to everything.
(Xolo laughs)
Don't invite me anywhere, I
might not show up, I'm terrible.
But supportive, I feel like I could do.
- I'm thinking supportive too.
- I would probably say brave.
I was gonna do ambitious, but-
- You can just say
that I have the best answers,
it's not a problem Jacob.
- [Mary] Now pick your biggest weakness.
- This is going to get so
personal for all of us.
(Mary laughs)
- And we all just start crying, right?
I get too emotionally attached?
(Jacob laughs)
I'm done, that's all I needed.
- I feel like this is a little targeted.
(Jacob laughs)
- I know, right?
I'm really insecure.
Ooh, (giggles) I'm a little selfish.
I trust too easily.
I'm kind of stubborn.
I'm a bit bossy.
- Can I only choose one?
(laughing)
- Can I get multiple choice?
To be fair, I feel like
insecurity definitely is
the thing that holds me back,
but boy, do I ever trust too easily?
I'm also stubborn as hell.
I mean, all right.
I'm just going to go with insecure,
because, let's be honest.
- I get too emotionally attached,
or I trust too easily.
- I went with stubborn.
- Yeah, you're stubborn as (beep)
- I wanna say I trust too easily.
- I think I'm stubborn.
- Yeah, we all think so too.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Peyton, I'm so glad I don't
have to work with these two
all the time like you do.
(Mary and Jacob laugh)
- The feeling's mutual,
don't worry.
- Choose a Cobra Kai character
you'd trust with a secret:
Pam, Miguel, Hawk,
Tori, Ayesha, or Robbie.
And I would have to go with Ayesha,
because I feel like she
was a great friend to Tori,
and I also feel like
she's super trustworthy
and I would trust her the most.
- I feel like there's so many bad answers.
I love Hawk, but no way in hell
would I tell that man anything.
Honestly, I would totally say Miguel.
- That's true.
- I'm gonna go with Robbie.
I trust Robbie.
I trust that Robbie has no one to tell.
- I chose myself.
There's no one that I can trust
better than myself, right?
You can't trust nobody out here.
Everyone's kissing each other,
and everyone's going
behind each other's backs
and backstabbing,
I can only trust myself.
- [Jacob] Choose a bad-ass
fictional character
to fight alongside:
Wonder Woman, Katniss Everdeen
from "The Hunger Games",
Adonis Creed from "Creed",
John McClane from "Die Hard",
Beatrix Kiddo from "Kill
Bill", and Black Panther.
- I'm gonna say Adonis
Creed right off the bat.
Wonder Woman and Katniss, they're awesome,
and Beatrix, they're all
fighting ladies, but like-
- Yes, we all want
Michael B. Jordan, Mary.
We know, it's okay.
- I'll be honest about it.
- I want to say Black Panther.
- I was about to say,
I think I would go with Black Panther too.
- I'm going with Beatrix from "Kill Bill".
I just watched that movie again,
and when she takes out the 88,
the Crazy 88s or whatever it
is, that's an insane scene.
I would want her on my side.
- [Xolo] All right, let's see,
how would you spend
your ideal Friday night?
At a party with my friends,
date night with my significant other,
inviting my closest friends
over to have a 'chill' night in.
Heh, kind of a weird...
- Weird vibes.
- [Xolo] Having a nice
homemade dinner with my family,
practicing because there
are no days off, duh,
or by myself watching
my favorite TV series.
- I'm not gonna lie,
I read the "having a nice homemade dinner"
as "having a nice homicide"
(Jacob laughing)
I was like, a nice homicide
with my family? Okay!
- I think even with the weird tilde
that was entered in there,
I think inviting my closest friends over
to have a chill night
in is something that,
definitely during quarantine,
that I'm doing more than anything.
- I'm gonna go with the same.
- Imma say date night.
- Date night with your significant other.
- I'm doing the closest friends.
I just think that's the most realistic.
- Pick an 80s movie to reboot:
The Breakfast Club, Beverly
Hills Cop, Back to the Future,
Heathers, Do the Right
Thing, or The Goonies.
I feel like Heather's kind of got a reboot
in the sense of the musical,
so I feel like I'm gonna
stick with The Breakfast Club.
- I'm gonna have to go
with Heathers for sure.
I love that movie.
- Beverly Hills Cop.
I really love that movie.
- Yeah,
I'm deciding between Beverly
Hills Cop and The Goonies.
I feel like The Goonies deserves it more.
- That's a weird way to phrase that.
- You just don't deserve it!
- [Peyton] Finally,
choose something important from Cobra Kai:
Hawk's tattoo,
All-Valley Karate Tournament,
Miguel's skeleton costume,
Mr. Miyagi's Medal of Honor, bonsai trees,
or Johnny's Coors banquet.
- I think for me, it's
Johnny's Coors banquet.
I think if there's anything
more synonymous with the show,
it's Johnny and his beer.
- I agree.
- As much as wanna say Hawk's tattoo,
I gotta do Johnny's beer.
It's the show, you know?
- You guys are a bunch of Cobra Kais.
I'm thinking Miyagi's medal
of honor, because technically,
that's the thing that started
the whole season two fight.
If you go far enough back
- Well I mean,
technically what started
the fight is your inability
to walk down a hill without
having to hold someone's hand.
But I mean-
(Jacob and Mary laugh)
(cool rock music)
Cobra Kai runs through my veins!
- Cobra Kai!
- Me too!
- What about you Mary?
- 100% Miyagi-Do
- I can't think
of anything I'd rather be
100% of than Cobra Kai.
- Cobra Kai runs through my veins.
You're smart, determined, and
stronger than all Miyagi-Dos.
- Please tell me that's not
actually what's written.
- That's really what's written.
- It says you're stronger
than all the Miyagi-Dos?
- (group) Yes!
- That's so
a Cobra Kai something to say.
You're 100% Miyagi-Do.
You're brave, level-headed, and resilient.
You're very in tune with your emotions
because they're usually
what motivate your actions.
- I think there was
never a doubt in my mind.
- I was questioning Peyton.
Cause I feel like knowing
Peyton in real life
you're such a nice person.
I was not expecting the
more cutthroat answers.
- Nah, she's pretty mean.
- We bonded last season,
and we went out and we had a lot of fun.
So she knows me well now
(Mary laughs)
- Apparently not well enough.
(cool rock music)